hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from round three of the
fiji grand prix currently being played
in belgrade serbia uh it's been
tallahare krishna versus anish giri and
a lot of you guys have requested this
game even before it finished and for
good reason so let's dive straight into
it and see what happened here uh hari
krishna has the white pieces and he
opens with e4
uh we have e5 by anish knight to f3
knight to c6 and bishop to b5 and allah
goes for the royal lopez with a6
challenging the bishop bishop to a4 that
being the morphe defense and now knight
to f6 we have castles uh offering the
pawn on e4 but this is a well-known
theory so anish captures it and now d4
uh you might think but why not rook to
e1 this clearly makes sense uh well you
could play that it's nothing uh serious
black will play knight this knight to c5
go after the bishop here and after
bishop captures the d captures on c6
knight captures on e5 we can play knight
to e6 preventing any nasty discoveries
and after let's say knight a queen to h5
going after checkmate we can play queen
to f6 and everything is perfectly fine
so this is one way to do it but a more
modern way is to just advance the pawn
to d4
we have b5 attacking the bishop bishop
to b3 and now d5 so black will give back
the e5 pawn uh d captures on e5 and now
bishop to e6 so this is very very very
solid for black knight beat to d2 and
now knight to c5 challenging the bishop
on b3 avoiding the trait here for the
knight and here we have c3 uh black says
a white says it rather you can capture
the bishop here but then my queen can
capture or otherwise i might just put my
bishop on c2 and grab hold of this long
diagonal so bishop to e7 and he's just
continuous development bishop to c2 and
now black strikes in the center with d4
so knights to b3 putting more pressure
on d4 and here we have d3 so it might
seem strange to allow something like
this but this is all a very standard
theory so bishop back to b1 now comes
knight captures on b3 a captures on b3
and now bishop to f5 defending the past
pawn on d3 so bishop to e3 continuing
development and now anish castles with
bishop to d4 uh discontinuing the
defense of the d3 pawn so now white is
ready to capture on d3 and here anish
just plays queen to d5 saying okay you
are welcome to capture on d3 but i'm
going to capture on b3 for example
bishop captures here we're going to have
queen bishop captures queen captures and
queen captures on b3 with black being
more than happy with with this position
so instead after queen to d5 we have
rook to e1 just adding more defenders to
the e5 pawn also developing the rook and
now there are a couple of games that
reach this exact same position one of
the more popular ideas is just pushing
the pawn to d2 and after queen captures
then we're going to play bishop capture
son b1 rook captures and then we're
gonna capture on b3 so this has been
played however uh alongside a couple of
other ideas that were played on each
plays a move that has never been played
before and that of course is pawn to b4
and now you see that he is trying to
undermine the bishop on d4 and what can
white do here
well you could just ignore this but you
could also contin just start capturing
so here we have bishop captures on d3
bishop captures on d3 queen captures and
now b captures on c3 we have b captures
on c3 and now queen captures on b3 so
the material on the board is even but
it's a very very interesting position as
black already has a past a pawn so white
uh
should have something in return for that
and here you could continue with
something like rook e to b1 try and
harass the queen then the queen goes to
the e6 and so on but if you don't do
this you can uh
advance the pawn to e6 right away
because if rookie to b1 then queen to e6
will block the pawn and hare krishna
really wants to
advance this pawn not only to open up
at the position but also the bishop now
gets uh hold of this diagonal uh
targeting that the g7 pawn so here f
captures on e6 for the moment the pawn
is defended so it's not a problem now
queen to e2 getting ready to pick up the
pawn and here we have a5 anish starts
advancing his past pawn and now the
thing is for example if queen captures
queen captures rook chapters here we're
going to play bishop to d6 and it's a
not something white really
wants to play i mean it it's uh black
who has the past a pawn so nothing
really to show for here so instead after
a4 uh we have this incredible c4 move
and this is where the game gets really
interesting and most likely why so many
of you have requested it uh here anish
can play a variety of moves one move is
knight captures on d4 we're going to
discuss this one rook captures an f3 is
another one also very interesting but
the move on each place is of course the
most interesting so here if knight
captures on d4 we're just gonna play
knight captures attack the queen and
after the queen moves attacks the knight
will probably see a capture on e6 and
attacking the rook and now rook f7 we
get this position where both players are
fairly happy with their position all in
all it's nothing really too dangerous
for black and it's still black who has
the past a pawn another thing instead of
knight captures on d4 we could also play
rook captures an f3 that's also a
possibility
now we're going to play queen captures
on e6 with check and now rook can go
back rook to f7 if you don't want to
capture the rook and allow knight
captures on d4 so we would probably see
this and then queen captures on c6 also
a pretty uh crazy position but uh
acceptable uh for for both white and
black however after c4 anish doesn't
play knight captures on d4 or rook
captures an f3 on each plays queen
captures an f3 and that's the good stuff
this is why so many of you have
suggested this and now the question is
what do you play here of course now
capturing with the queen is out of the
question as the rook guards the queen so
here we have the capture with the g pawn
uh so uh we uh or rather you could try
this even queen captures row captures
but then after g captures and f3 knight
captures on d4 and the bishop and the
knight against the rook it's just much
much better for black again it's only
black who has the past a pawn so this
would be very one-sided so instead after
this queen captures an f3 we have g
captures on f3 and now knight captures
on d4 so grabbing two pieces for the
queen uh here you can see that now the
bishop and knight will uh try and fight
against the white queen and also it's
very nice that the knight is guarding
the e6 pawn so we don't have to worry
about losing that right away so queen to
e4 putting pressure on the knight and
now knight captures on f3 with check
we're gonna win even more material so
king to h1 yeah you do not want to play
king to f1 this is something that might
happen to you in blitz and then you run
into knights to d2 uh a nice royal fork
so instead king to h1 and now knight
captures an e1 so before capturing we
want to get rid of this pawn queen
captures an e6 rook to f7 blocking check
and also adding a defender to the bishop
on e7 and now rook captures an e1 and
now if you look at the position
anisha has a rook and the bishop for a
queen plus the past a pawn so if white
doesn't do something very quickly that
pass pawn is going to start marching
forward so here we have rook to f8 anish
abandons the uh the idea of pushing the
pawn and now he's going after the f2
pawn so what can white do here he plays
rook to d1 uh he wants to bring the rook
to d7 and then put pressure on black's
position so here king to h8 now we first
have to unpin if we want to
start you know wreaking havoc along the
f file and now rook to d7 going after
the bishop here and here we have rook
captures on f2
uh it's hard to get out of this pin you
can't really move the bishop otherwise
you're just gonna
lose the game so here rook captures on
f2 is pretty much the only move we have
queen captures on e7 now threatening
checkmate on g7 and now rook to f1 with
check we have king to g2 and now rook
one to f2 with check king g1 we have
rook to f1 with czech king to g2 and
rook 1 to f2 with check here king g1 was
played and he was in this position on
move 35 that the players agreed to a
draw or rather it was a draw by
threefold repetition so a very nice
positional queen sacrifice by anish who
extends his lead in the
uh in the phoenix grand prix so very
nicely done and uh you can't push this
or anything uh with white even though
you have a queen for example if you just
continue with let's say rook f1 king g2
and now even if black tries something uh
king the g3 rook f3 checking g4 rook f4
check you can always play king to g5 and
now after h6 with check you can play
king to h5 and now uh what do you what
do you play here we're gonna play rook
to g1 of course we have to defend
against checkmate but now rook captures
on c7 so it's it doesn't seem like
anything great is happening here you can
even give up the queen here it's not a
problem rogue g5 check captures capture
so we're going to play king captures on
g5 and now let's say rook to f6
defending our rook rook to a7 going
after this pawn we're going to play rook
to c6 going after this pawn and now when
i straight here captures captures and of
course this is now a draw um by just
looking at it i mean uh everyone knows
that this is a draw so of course after
came to g1 there's not much to play for
uh the players agree to a draw but what
uh what a great theoretical struggle and
what uh what a a wonderful choice of
after uh achieving this brand new
position with a move like before to even
getting such a such a move to sacrifice
the queen and it's uh okay uh you of
course have winning chances but a draw
is more than enough for anish to uh
solidify his lead in the in defeated
grand prix
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh if you have any other uh
favorites do use hashtag suggestion and
i will go over them i would like to
thank ukraine for defending europe uh
four stars ptn gregory bosch ronan
mcgovern and tomas turner for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
video grand prix until it ends so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day